good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
monday we hope everyone had a fabulous
weekend and is feeling refreshed
maybe hungover that's okay welcome back
to the morning toast i'm so excited hi
jax
hi how are you doing i'm great i'm so
great because i'm with theo
of course and i didn't want to just like
jump into something so negative
i literally i literally knew what you
were gonna do
i and i think i think it has to be done
because something so devastating
happened this weekend
um you and i were hanging out on
saturday and we are fabulous today
you're having such a fabulous day and
luckily for me
you had made some plans that evening and
you asked if i could take
to do the adora and i was overjoyed you
know
he came over you told me he was going to
sleep by me and
we started watching yellowstone together
i took him out for a late night walk
i washed his paws we got into bed i
moved the love sack from my living room
to my bed if you have a movie-sized love
sack you know it's
that's a big thing it's huge it's huge
and we're in bed it's 12 30 and my
sister texts me and she says hey are you
up and it's like i knew what you were
texting me for but i'm not going to
ignore your text because you're my
sister like
you know i'm going to be there for you
yes i was up
uh she calls me and says that her and
ben are coming to take theo like we were
literally in bed together
perched watching yellowstone cleaned
happy boys and girls
and it was all just it was ripped away
from me i just feel like i'm not gonna
lie like
it was so hurtful i think you are
intentionally leaving out an
integral part of the story yeah to fit
your own narrative it was part of the
story when you asked me to
watch him and have him sleep over yes
when i asked you to watch him it was
never fully clear whether or not he was
sleeping over like we were gonna figure
it out
and i would have let you keep him
literally for the whole weekend but you
don't have any of his food at your house
i know so he wasn't gonna eat breakfast
because
and like only because you wanted him
like that's just so selfish no he had
just had dinner when he came over so we
would have woken up and i would have
taken
him home he would have done a little
intermittent fast like a mini
no i didn't think it was good for him
and
and he had a carrot and i got home
earlier than expected like if it was
four in the morning i would have just
left him there but i got him at a
reasonable hour
at 1am i'm a reasonable mom like sorry
i'm sorry that that happened to you
obviously it's okay i mean i understand
like i
i understand here's what they understand
it just it just hurts
are you like snatchler will you learn
your lesson and buy some food for your
house oh
for sure for sure except like when you
don't have a dog and you just have dog
food like the food does smell but
no it's called like a ziploc just like
you'll zip it up i can like i know i
don't have food
in my house because i don't smell it
well you obviously don't care enough
that's what i'm saying no i will have
food next time
i will learn my lesson i just you know
when you give him a bath and he gets so
riled up
like and he's like runs around like he
scrapes his head on the ground like
barking in my apartment at
midnight and we got past that stage you
know
calmed him down he was liking
yellowstone too because of all the
horses and the animals
which by the way i'm like knee balls
deep in yellowstone and it's so [ __ ]
good
and i need for you to watch it we'll
recap it we have so much to recap in our
tv
segment i watched so much tv this
weekend so did you we have our twist
movie of the week recap
so that'll obviously as always be at the
end of the show but yes we have a heavy
a fat recap section today very
very fat we also have the fast five
obviously lots of things did happen over
the weekend you know
stones were unturned yeah stones were
turning they were turning stones
and so it's gonna be a great show i just
had to get that off my chest but other
than that i had i had a really
nice relaxing weekend where i feel like
i consumed a lot of content
and participated you know in the content
consummation
of our nation i too consumed a lot of
content but i also made a fabulous piece
of content last night you did you were a
content creator and the reviews are in
and they're pretty spectacular um you
know olivia our sister
is a new mom and she's been really
offline and she talks a lot about why
she made that decision i'm her podcast
maternity leave has been
on pause and she spoke a lot about um
she's like struggling with whether or
not she should come back because you
know once you have a kid like your
priorities are so different
not only like time management wise but
you just want to protect your child and
she got you know a really unnecessary
amount of hate towards the end of her
pregnancy and i think that kind of like
scarred her
and we talk a lot about that on the
podcast episode in addition to her birth
story
um and for those wondering why she
didn't do it on maternity live you'll
hear why on the podcast
she's just unsure and i think doing
things on patreon makes everyone feel a
little safer because it is behind this
wall um it was really funny i mean we
literally recorded the whole episode
while she was pumping and like her
nipples were straight up in my face
that's so funny you love that
i love that i'm just like constantly
marveled by the the spectacular nature
of the female form like
it just what like what was happening in
front of me was a miracle yeah
it was crazy it's a miracle but it
happens every day
in every way it's no it's just so common
it's like yep my boobs
make milk and it's just crazy my baby
and it's the only thing baby can eat no
it makes so much sense like you know
evolution is fantastic
um so we we did her birth story we were
just talking about like new mom all like
the funny gadgets she has like she has a
special machine to pick
michaela's nose it was really great um
it's a podcast episode it's up on the
patreon patreon.com
if you want to check it out people are
loving it and i had so much fun doing it
like any excuse to go over to olivia's
house now
yeah now that she's got that baby i mean
always just hanging out with mick
it's she's the coolest chick in the
world it's life-changing
it is life-changing and it's like really
it's so funny leaving her department
her apartment is really like an
emotional roller coaster because when
you're sitting
on her couch just like holding mikayla
like truly nothing else in the world
matters
there's no instagram drama there's
really like there's no pandemic it's
like you're just looking at this
fresh life and like the second you close
her door behind you it's like
back to the terrible real world stark
contrast
it's so stark and it's like you really
never want to leave her house
no i i feel you that's why she doesn't
yes and we spoke about that too
oh perfect well i'm really excited to
listen i've been getting into
podcasts well on friday night i spent
the majority of my night watching joe
rogan
because he too films his show and it's
on youtube he does
three hour episodes i know everyone
knows everything about joe rogan how
many times
a week i think he does like multiple
episodes a week wow that's a long time
yeah and he
he's just like so great at the job and
it was a pleasure to watch him
and i just feel like i have a renewed
podcasting energy i would love to
watching joe rogan i just i'm feeling
more emboldened than ever you know to do
the job
we love it in boldenstein yeah he's just
so like
he he he is the real deal he's mecca
like a podcaster even though like i
didn't know that much about him before
watching the show like he was everything
i thought he was even though i had
limited information you know i feel that
so it was just really enjoyable um i
know it's the number one podcast in the
world so i don't have to tell you guys
listen to it because you probably
already do
but it's crazy how long the episodes are
because sometimes i feel like our
episodes are
are long and people don't even have that
much time but like millions of people
sit down and listen to these three hour
intellectual conversations
on the daily no when you really think
about what joe rogan has done like for
the medium and just like the business
he's carved out for himself like you
can't think about it too long because
it's so impressive like
just the sheer volume of people who have
watched a show
for so long and how many new people
watch just like you like every day just
discovering it
it's really the most incredible thing
and he weirdly has like
legs in a million different things like
he does sports right yeah well he
started as an mma fighter and now he
does sports commentary i was on his
wikipedia he used to be the host of fear
factor
oh i listened to an episode and he was
like when we were filming very factor i
was like what
yeah interesting very interesting i
thought maybe he was a contestant but
now he was the host
fear factor is well i don't i don't know
if it's still on but like when it was at
its heyday i think it was on like mtv or
something it was the craziest show i
know we weirdly used to watch it
i would that's like the last reality
show i would ever go on yeah
i would rather go on the bachelor and
like have to be in a bikini all day
then lay in a bathtub of roaches yeah
and then eat them
disgusting sickening the things and the
things that used to make people do like
yeah sick i don't know what the prize
was but it wasn't enough
the presence of joe rogan is the prize
um so yes anything else we want to talk
about recap from the weekend before we
dive in
uh no i think that's all she heard i
started the redheads book last night
because we're recording this week the
episode drops the first thursday
of every month so the first thursday of
august um
and it's actually it's really really
good it's
i'm not that far into it yet but i
really like the writing style it makes
me feel like
it's a quote-unquote easy way to read it
and i'm really looking forward to the
discussion
so if you want to become a redhead you
know that it's never too late
it's pick up [ __ ] star never never
too late never too late claude
oh me yeah i don't know how you guys
read the book so fast like that's what
i know you give everyone a month and
like you read a book in a day but like i
literally need three months to read a
book
yeah no jesse well the jessica simpson
book was really long but it still took
me like
more than a month yeah i'd like to be
rushed and you know what it is it's like
i don't want to feel like i have
homework you know
no i know sometimes it does start to
feel like homework but then we do the
homework and we're so much better off
for
it and i'm like oh i'm so glad you know
i hadn't read a book in like a week and
if it wasn't for the redheads i wouldn't
be reading right now i just would have
like finished watching yellowstone
and it really it forces you to get back
and read these books that are all so
different from one another
and i think it's just a great passion
that i'm passionate about i have to say
even though you know facebook groups are
a thing of the past the redheads group
is
going strong so cute it's literally the
nicest group and it's just like filled
with people who want to share things
that they love
and recommend things to other people
yeah no it really is the nicest group i
don't want to jinx it but like everyone
in the redheads is a sweetie
yeah don't change it the jinx is [ __ ]
real
okay so i guess without further ado
because there has been much ado about
kind of nothing
we could get into the fast side stories
that you yes you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and that's true and you know as always
today's episode is brought to you by our
patreon
patreon.com morning toast the month of
july has four episodes already there
will be one more coming this week
and then we start again august 5 fresh
new videos or podcast i think you guys
will really enjoy it
again it's 7.99 for a monthly
subscription of five extra episodes from
jackie and i
vlogs audio podcasts anything you can
dream of and of course access
to our last remaining facebook group the
toast after dark which is
super exclusive only patreon members
allowed
and it's fabulous yes quite fabulous are
you ready for our first story i'm so
ready
it's a sad one because regis philbin has
died the iconic tv host actor singer and
all-around media personality who was
once dubbed
the hardest working man in showbiz
passed away this weekend
this is according to a statement from
his family they told people quote his
family and friends are forever grateful
for the time
we got to spend with him for his warmth
his legendary sense of humor and his
singular ability to make every day into
something worth talking about
we think that's really beautiful yeah we
thank his fans and admirers for their
incredible support over his 60-year
career
a source tells cmz that regis died early
saturday after suffering a heart attack
at his home
possibly the one in connecticut although
they have not confirmed that with the
family how old was he at that point
he was 88 years old i mean what a life
what a legacy
um when i think of regis philbin i think
of his very small cameo and miss
congeniality i don't know why
yeah that's literally all i can think
about maybe because i didn't really grow
up watching live with regis and kelly
you know that's so funny because when i
was thinking about him this morning i
was like i associate him with mrs
congeniality but that's william shatner
but no they're both in it and they're
both very similar same exact person
and i'm so glad to understand why i
assumed regis was in that movie
and he asked the iconic question if you
what is your idea of the perfect date
oh yes that was him yes april 25th
because it's not too hot and it's not
too cold
all you need is a light jacket um i mean
this is
of course death is sad but sometimes we
report on death like when it's a tragedy
and to me like regis philbin lived such
i mean i didn't know him but what a
powerful meaningful legacy he leaves
behind
88 is a long time and i think that
people in the industry were forever
impacted i mean
when you think of regis what do you
think live with regis and kelly right
and so
i actually didn't see it but i got so
many dms of people sending me kelly's
post
about regis like really disappointed in
her response
because she posted a picture from like a
million years ago of her
regis and ryan yes and mickey mouse i
see it here with a statement that
ryan also posted like so it was just
like this is the statement yeah we are
beyond saddened to learn about the loss
of regis philbin he was the ultimate
class act bringing his laughter and joy
into our homes every day on live for
more than 23 years
we were beyond lucky to have him as a
mentor in our careers and aspire every
day to fill his shoes on the show
we send our deepest love and condolences
to his family and hope they can find
some comfort in knowing he left the
world a better place
which is obviously lovely but when it's
copy and pasted on both ryan and kelly's
instagram i think a lot of people took
that as disingenuous
well also because kelly worked with him
for so many years whereas ryan was
never hosted the show with him like
permanently no now ryan takes over his
legacy of the hardest working man in
hollywood oh
for sure which is actually perfect that
ryan filled his shoes totally
uh so i agree that people might have
wanted something more personal from for
kel from kelly but
you know what how people grieve is just
true no business of ours
i mean i literally saw two instagram
posts from snooki who was like
devastated because when they used to do
press for jersey shore i guess they went
on
and she had some sort of connection with
him and i thought her post was literally
so sweet and more genuine than kelly who
worked with him for years
again you obviously don't know how
people are grieving i just thought a lot
of people i thought it was interesting
how many people like sent it to me
and thought it was just interesting yeah
i guess so i just i'm
i'm remiss to criticize the way that's
what someone posts on social media
because
so many times like it's social media is
nonsense it's not indicative of how
anyone feels about anything and if
someone doesn't want to bear their soul
on their instagram account they don't
have to
that works for me i agree but kathy lee
gifford also posted something really
sweet
um it's just he was a loved man and he
lived a large and long life
and that's really all you can ask for in
this world it's but it's still yeah
it's still a loss for sure yeah i mean
now i'll never be able to watch that
movie again without just being sad
uh miss congeniality continuality yeah
an iconic cameo
okay next story is some exciting egot
news because the daytime emmy
2020 winners they did a virtual show
etcetera etcetera
to say they did a virtual show and one
of the hosts was tabitha brown
my favorite tick tocker getting the
respect that she deserves she's like the
vegan
yes yes yes oh my god i [ __ ] love her
and she was just in vanity fair and now
she's hosting
the virtual emmys and it's just a great
year for tabitha brown
yes um the second round of winners for
the 47th annual daytime emmy awards were
unveiled on sunday night as the ceremony
handed out trophies honoring children's
lifestyle and
animation programming the ceremony also
paid tribute to regis philbin who passed
away
this weekend by sharing his acceptance
speech for the lifetime achievement
award he received in 2008. oh wow
um so the winners of the daytime emmys
are out which is interesting sure but we
have a new egot
in our mix who alan menken the composer
he's composed everything fabulous he did
beauty and the beast
aladdin the little mermaid beast he's
obviously
a world renowned everything of the sort
little shop of horrors newsies hunchback
of notre dame what did he win now
oh my god he composed enchanted which is
the most underrated film
of all time i don't think i've ever seen
it yes you have with amy adams where she
goes
being a cartoon i know i really don't
think i've ever seen it claudia it's
beautiful i know
it's so good and james marsden is in it
and the music is so good
anything james marsden is in is fabulous
ever ever
after that's out i know that's all
wow how interesting so what did he win
the emmy for this round oh
inter assange let me scroll down the
list
and he became the 16th person to
achieve an egot which is interesand we
only have 16 hopefully 17 soon david
foster we're pulling for you or 18 lady
gaga she's kind of close
is she um yeah oscar she has grammy
she needs the emmy she didn't win that
time no but she does do
tv so it's like it's not so far off she
already has her toe in the pond
yeah i agree the emmy could happen i'm
not sure what alan menken just won for
whatever um another interesting thing
that i saw who won an emmy very randomly
was ally brook from fifth harmony ooh
she had a co-written or written um a
theme song for like a children's
tv show that won an emmy so he won for
best original song
um with along with glenn slater for
rapunzel's tangled adventure
fabulous so fabulous i mean like
i'm so familiar with his work and not
the man and he's just seems so deserving
because he's
a part of everything that's fabulous so
who are egots i know um
john legend is an ego whoopi goldberg
that's literally the only one i know
and i only know that from that episode
of 30 rock where
tracy wants to become an egot so he
calls will be goldberg okay
here are the egots i feel like we
probably won't know the names
yeah no we're not going to know a lot of
these people richard rogers who's a
composer
i believe that's rogers and hammerstein
you know the roger
son do not quote me you know what even
if it's not like
i like that narrative it might as well
but you know even if it's not like i'm
going to pretend like it is
helen hayes so she was an actress i
don't know her
uh rita moreno donna
john gielgud no no audrey hepburn wow
fabulous marvin hamlik unclear
jonathan tunic who a lot of these people
are composers and connectors yes
conductors
mel brooks oh i mean if you think about
it like
who really can transcend four totally
entirely different industries and it's
really the music it's really the music
so it makes sense like john legend um
has one
mike nichols whoopi goldberg love yeah
oh they mentioned this article from
mentalfloss.com mentions the episode of
30 rock that's the only reason i know it
she walks around with the egot necklace
scott rudin robert lopez um andrew lloyd
webber john legend and tim rice
i have heard of andrew lloyd webb oh and
there are some she gots
barbra streisand liza minnelli james
earl jones oh
oh i'm sorry these were people who are
um close
sorry it's worth the there are a handful
of other other famous faces who have
also earned all four awards but because
at least one of them is a special or
honorary award only
not a competitive one their inclusion in
the club is questionable right like a
lifetime achievement emmy
okay so that's barbra streisand liza
minnelli james earl jones alan menken
but now he's
legit legit harry belafont quincy jones
and then we have almost egots are do you
want to hear those sure
i'm so obsessed with he got dumb it's
fascinating okay almost egots
julie andrews lin-manuel miranda oh
he'll get it
martin scorsese oh that's interesting he
needs a tony
francis mcdormand oh she'll get it viola
davis
she'll get it randy newman don't know
him al pacino
i think i've heard of him john williams
unclear cher needs a tony
shared i mean their share the musical
just came out did not win any choice
because that's so true
they got to step it up elton john oh i i
thought he wasn't
for sure he needs an emmy i feel like he
could get one like right
like no literally give one of your old
songs that you threw in the trash too
ryan murphy or something uh ron howard
and brian grazer
and trey parker and matt stone also i
think it's worth mentioning you know who
i think is going to get one in their
lifetime but they're pretty new on the
scene
ben platt those guys uh pasik and
paul yes from um from grady show me yes
and from
dear evan hansen but can i also just um
get recognized for my fabulous answer
ben platt already has a tony he was
nominated for a couple emmys he might
have won one
um he has a very long career ahead of
him and he does so much musical theater
um which is the key because it's the
music that you really need to get an
egot
yeah but he has the tony so right i
think he could get a grammy
what do you think is the hardest one to
get it depends on who you are i think
for a lot of people
david foster foster yeah you know but
for ben platt it's the first one he got
or it would probably be the hardest for
him to get an oscar because he's
transitioning from musical theater
to tv and then into movies which is the
hardest jump to make but he's so
talented i have no doubt
yeah it's tough i wonder if when they're
like granting the awards if
the they take into consideration
consideration i wonder if they want more
egots or they want to keep it like
so competitive i'm sure they want to
keep it like prestigious
yeah but it sounds super prestigious
already not as precise
that is only the creme de la creme
speaking of creme de la creme when it
comes to my eyes i
only prefer the cream ah of course and
that's why felix gray is better
there are a lot of blue light glasses on
the market but they are not all created
equal
many blue light glasses don't filter
enough blue light especially in the
range that matters
most screens produce blue light at a
certain point in the spectrum of 455
nanometers
and most clear blue light lenses only
filter about two to three percent
in that range felix gray uses a
proprietary filtering technology to
filter 15 times more blue light in the
same range
they filter out 90 of the blue light in
most damaging range and eliminates 99
of glare through a proprietary
industry-leading technology only
available with felix gray
glare is real i never realized that
because i'm new to the glasses front
i've gotten glasses of astigmatism
for like the last maybe two three years
when i watch tv and in the dark like
glass glare is so real it gives me and
i'm prone to migraines it gives me the
worst headache when i'm looking at like
a blurry screen it really doesn't even
help
and then i watch so much tv and scroll
on tick-tock before bed so much
that i didn't even know blue light is
like a very real thing and it can keep
you up if you're not wearing it
it makes your brain think that it's
daytime so that's why blue light
blocking glasses are so fabulous because
then it's like what do you want glare
that should be their slogan felix gray
what do you want glare
um felix gray frames are hand finished
from durable super lightweight italian
acetate
if you order online the glass is shipped
directly to you with a hard case and a
lens cloth included
oh my god lens cloths are so fabulous
like you think you could clean your
glasses on like your dirty t-shirt you
cannot
i don't know what it is about the
specific cloth but it's like this
proprietary fabulous technology
lens cloths over loin cloths so true
every day
and that's the magic of felix gray try
them for 30 days
risk-free if your screens aren't easier
on the eyes send them back for a full
refund but i'm pretty sure you won't
want to do that
go to felix grayglasses.com toast for
the absolute best quality blue light
filtering glasses on the market
that's felix gray f e l i x g
r a y glasses dot com slash toast
shipping and returns are totally free at
felixgrayglasses.com
toast f-e-l-i-x g-r-a-y glasses dot com
slash toast sign on c right
sign on what do you want glare okay
you're ready for our next story it's
like an opportunity for you to talk
about the only thing that you probably
want to talk about the biermanns
no oh that's always what i want to talk
about folklore oh yeah yeah yeah i'm
sorry we have another story i thought
you were like setting me up for the
vanessa morgan story
oh no no sorry i'm i didn't realize you
wanted to talk about the biermanns more
than you want to talk about taylor right
now
no no i just i was trying to like you
were throwing me a bottle i know i i
understand a lot but i was trying to
dunk it and i just totally failed
i understand i'm sorry it's my fault
don't be sorry
no but like it was my fault i set up the
shot and no missed 100
it's on both players no i think it's on
you
blake lively praises taylor swift's
folklore after singer reveals the name
of actress's baby girl
blake lively has nothing but wonderful
world words to say
about taylor swift's latest release the
actress shared a supportive message to
the musician
whose new album folklore which was
released on friday included a track that
confirmed the name
of lily and ryan reynolds is third
daughter who was born last year
in her note lively extended her
gratitude to swift album producers aaron
desner and jack antonoff
as well as singers bonnie there now that
i know how to pronounce bonnie bear like
i can't be stopped
but that's not how i pronounce it bon
either no that's not how i pronounce it
either
bony bear oh [ __ ] i don't even know how
to pronounce it i'm not sure i mean my
friend jason abramson
is bony bear's number one fan like he
was talking about boney bear when i was
in high school i'm like oh you think
you're so cool
now he's a song with taylor shift i'm
like oh my god bony bear and he says
boni veron in high school everyone was
like bon iver so i'm gonna go with jason
on this one
up until recently i think that he it's a
he
yeah like it's not a group no no it's a
um
play coachella and that was when i
learned that it's bony bear
you know i could see how you know a
jaded american such as yourself
would think it's bon iver but as phoebe
buffet once said you americans always
butcher the french language
um okay so this is what blake lively had
to say can we all please crawl inside
that piano with you and live in this
album like you folklore is full of heart
soul humor passion intelligence
wit whimsy reality imagination strength
vulnerability and above all things love
that's really sweet
after the album drop the singers fans
who are pros at picking up on the clues
we're quick to note that the track betty
appeared to drop some major news
about their nine month old they said
that the lyrics to the song featured
three names betty inez and james
the latter two being the names of
reynolds and lively's three and a half
and five-year-old daughters
right so everyone thinks that inez i
mean the thing is it's like there are
there are three songs on the album true
swifties know
that they're all break it down for the
for the people who just listen to music
and enjoy it okay and i want to go
through
all the songs really quickly but there
are three songs on the album august
cardigan
and betty that are supposedly about a
love triangle from three different
perspectives
and all the characters in the love
triangles have names and she references
them betty is obviously one of them
james is one and what's the third yes
thank you well no she's not in the love
story
she's just the girl who's constantly
saying rumors you heard the rumors from
me mess
you can't believe a word she says but
this time
it was true so she's not a main
character i think she just
used the baby's names as like
inspiration it's totally impossible
really starting stuff at three and a
half years old i don't
think so okay again unclear because
taylor is very overt sometimes
but it's always so subtle it's like we
could be making this all up in our heads
you never know and i feel like if she's
writing about three people and it's like
that and this is kind of what she did
when she had
the kid on the song that was like
gorgeous
um where it's like a fun fact for this
kid who
gets their name in like an iconic piece
of
writing totally so i think she probably
just borrowed the names
yeah no i don't think it has like any
you know weird meaning yeah yeah i'm not
saying that the baby's starting stuff
no and the word i mean the word um the
name inez is so fabulous for songwriting
because it rhymes
yeah it's not like claudia what the [ __ ]
rhymes with claudia dodia
thank you um and just quickly back to
the album it's been really fabulous to
see
so many people like coming out and
supporting the album like celebrities
people who aren't traditional taylor
swift stands
i mean of course as an og like you know
you feel a little bit of resentment it's
like everyone's like this album's
amazing like yeah i know
like of course it is but i'm ultimately
happy that like everyone's getting on
board
because every one of the people who are
some of the standout people who
spoke about it who aren't in her usual
circle angie cohen was listening to it
all weekend on his instagram stories and
he tweeted about it like i can't stop
listening to it really cool
um yeah no and it's just been like like
even my friend i don't know why i'm
talking about him so much but jason
abramson who like loves boney bear
um i'm always trying to get him to
listen to taylor because he like loves
music and he like gets it and
appreciates it from afar but like i was
like you have to listen to this album
listen to x y and z he's like i already
listened to it this song with bony bear
is
so good beautiful it's called exile it's
a collab between the two i think it's
you know the two of them talking about a
relationship
and a breakup from like two totally
different perspectives and it's funny
how like you could literally go through
something with someone and you two see
it
so differently yeah you have two
completely different stories i learned
that that's what the song was about from
snatchler's folklore reaction video
which was definitely check out after you
finish this episode
so again i i don't think i've even had
enough time to come up with a couple
favorites because
it's such a first of all it's 16 songs
it's a big album and it's
filled with just so many nuggets like i
can't even begin to tell you
what my top three are but here are some
standouts immediately the last great
american dynasty i mean
the fact that taylor can write a bop
about a woman who lived in the house
before she lived in it is just
song writing at its finest exile i love
my tears ricochet is is a favorite for a
lot of people
i'm obsessed with the story and the
lyrics i'm not obsessed with the song i
just i can
i i think that the song is about scott
borchetta and
the whole drama of like her losing her
art and losing scott borchetta who was
like a
part of her family for like the last 12
years and there's a line in it that it's
like
when you can't sleep at night do you
hear my stolen lullabies which is like
definitely about scott porchetta and
it's just really beautifully done
although it's not like my favorite
melodically
okay um i love the song august i feel
like it
should have been like the ending credits
of a 90s rom-com
like a bottle of wine because you were
never mine
it's just so it's so ninety it's so
credited
music video for it and she i mean she
would never do this because it's like
two girls but do you like what ariana
grande did and do like a recreation of a
fabulous 90s movie
or like make your own rom-com like and
and have the song like the song
i just can't hear the song without
literally thinking i'm watching the
credits yeah she needs to call up on
alex davis and make it happen
she needs to call up had alex davis um
and probably my favorite song on the
album right now is illicit affairs i
just think it's
so good and anytime taylor talks about
um like something
adolescent like when she talks about the
high school or like frames a song
in like a school scene it just it tugs
at my heartstrings because that's how
she started writing about like high
school
um and an illicit affair she has a
fabulous line about meeting someone
behind the mall and it's just
so like og taylor and that's what i love
about it and elicit affairs has a little
bit of a beat you know it's a slow album
but
you can dance to illicit affairs nice
and i love
peace and betty those are my tops peace
is just
really really beautiful and betty is an
actual country song like there's a
harmonica on it
it's so good i feel like that is the one
that is sort of rising
from from the others the creme de la
creme even though it's all so crummy
you know what they say about cream it
rises to the top yeah creme i don't
that means cream i know you guys are
from new jersey quote from my comedy
special disgrace
me and you want to hear a little fun
fact that was improv like that was i
didn't have that joke written no it was
it was so good it was so funny i
remember like now i remember that while
i was at the show it killed me it was
like one of the things i was hearing for
the first time and then when i watched
the special
that was just so fabulous and
life-changing it killed me once again
thank you so much again
disgraced queen now streaming i can't
believe you know i know i'm being so
annoying like talking about it so much
but you know when you release a project
there's like a couple days where there's
so much buzz about it and then like
everyone forgets about it
with their life especially in the
influencer world and especially in the
pandemic it's like everyone's just on to
bigger and better things
yeah it's kind of like everyone's just
trying to get it over with like they
have something that they need to launch
and like they're like please just let it
pass
yeah and so i mean what are we three
weeks out now it came out june 30th
almost a month literally i got tagged in
so many stories over the weekend like
people
who hadn't found the time to watch it
yet and like it really just means so
much to me that like people like it
because
i've done a lot of things in my career
most of which i'm not proud of but like
i am so proud of this one because
like i think it's so good speaking of
things that you've done in your career
i watched say yes to the dress i watched
well our friend kristen was just
on i need to watch her episode she's so
fabulous and liz is in it and her
friends healthy
from from dynasty fallon is our friend
kristen's best friend from like she's
her maid of honor
and so she that's just like such a treat
and it's such a sweet episode but it got
me in the spirit of say yes to the dress
and i don't think i've watched our
episode in full
other than the clips that people send me
on instagram and snapchat i haven't
watched the whole thing in full since it
came out for sure i don't think i've
ever even actually seen it in full
like it's so i'm so ashamed of it like
so crazy
i understand why why you don't like it's
not your favorite thing because like
it really was so crazy how the woman was
like this might be the first bride i've
ever been afraid of when you
legit said i said that yeah when you
legit said like i just want long sleeves
the rest i'm open and she was like
so constrict like you're like running
around the store like i asked for the
most complicated black snake skin dress
you were so particular she said when you
had one criteria
like honestly you didn't have enough
specifications no people come in i want
a sweetheart neckline mermaid tail i'm
like i don't care i just want long
sleeves because it's a religious wedding
and i don't like my arms so it's like
therefore me being insecure about my
arms is
me being difficult it's also just i
think it's just the trope of the show
i hold nothing against the consultant
she was lovely she was lovely but it was
just so funny to like see
us also the sisters i guess it's
four years ago more more
more i think it does it feels like ten
years ago okay but
i think in reality it's four years ago
my hair is so short oh yeah i got
married it was before i started using a
full coverage foundation it was 2016.
okay four years ago like legit almost to
the day
literally to the day was fall of 2016.
um and it's just like the way that we
were all talking we're like totes
like gorgina but they like made us do
that they did i couldn't maybe you know
what you know that's a
fabulous patreon episode me and us
watching and we'll tell you the stuff
that they made us do
like that's a good idea and all the
social media stuff stop
like seriously stop i know i know they
they just forced us to be so cringy but
like i was so excited to be on the show
the episode came out really really cute
i mean obviously we're our own
worst critics and it's your episode so
you probably look at it the most harshly
but i think other people really enjoy it
like
we look we're cute you know i think we
loved to have been there
for you as a bride like i think being
like a sister or a bridesmaid is like
the best part you have to try on dresses
you just get to sit and enjoy like being
on tv
yeah it's exciting yeah and it's like
you're not they're not trying to make
you out to look bad
even though sometimes they really pit
like bridesmaid against bride made in
certain episodes that didn't happen with
us
um but i do really want to see kristen's
episode yeah you should watch it
okay next story a little update on a
story from last week but kanye's
apologizing to kim on twitter
saying please forgive me he tweeted i
would like to apologize to my wife kim
for going public with something that was
a private matter i did not cover her
like she has covered me
to kim i want to say i know i hurt you
please forgive me thank you for always
being there for me
i mean the irony is that he's publicly
apologizing for being public
yeah i'm sure they've spoken about it
privately and that he's apologized
privately but i think he needs to close
the loop
with the public you know because we
still haven't heard
him you know i think they were just
closing the book on this chapter
i also heard i also heard that he like
checked himself into
the hospital in coding did you hear that
no i didn't hear that there were
paparazzi pictures of him
um like it's unclear if it was like for
him and for his mental health but there
are pictures of him at cody
whatever the hospital is called cody
international in general
cody jenner cody general yes it's yes
yes yes
um there are pictures is that what it's
called i'm sure i don't [ __ ] know
um cody sinai i don't know um
cody hill okay i'm done um i don't know
if it was
for him or if it was maybe he broke his
wrist i don't know but there are photos
of him
walking into a hospital which is a good
sign that is a good sign yeah no i'm
glad that things are quieting down
and he's he's apologized on twitter
which i think is is good for the world
even though i personally like
it and i think they have you know their
husband and wife and they communicate
and i'm
i think it's okay but i'm i look forward
to you know putting this in the rear
view
me too i'm like over talking about it
i'm not gonna lie yeah so i know you
want to talk about our fifth and final
story i do
i'm gonna jump right in riverdale star
vanessa morgan is pregnant and claudia
ashrae has a lot of thoughts
well here's why it's so let me re let me
just read the announcement
multi-faceted my interest in this story
but please riverdale actress vanessa
morgan is pregnant and expecting a baby
boy with her husband michael kopech
she wrote on instagram quote was
debating keeping this part of my life
hidden but i knew people would want to
see pictures eventually with my belly
and i wanted you guys to hear it from me
i do want to keep this chapter of my
life
private but did want to be the first to
share the news she said um it's almost
like everything i thought mattered in
this life has completely changed
we're here for such a greater purpose
and life is so precious i can't believe
how much my growth and strength
how much growth and strength you've
already given me as your mom it's like
god knew i needed you my angel
she added a few more uh sweet notes um
but overall she's so excited and so
happy so here's why the story really
piqued my interest
one i always forget that vanessa morgan
from riverdale
tony topaz got married to michael kopeck
who you might think is just like a
low-level mlb player which he is
but it's very important to not forget
that he was on one season of don't be
tardy for the party
with the biermanns because he himself
was dating brielle biermann
when he was in the minor leagues and
like there was talk about him getting to
the major leagues
and she like kind of like found him and
like started dating him and then they
were together for so long and they were
like really going strong and a lot of
people ship them
and then one day he broke up with or i
don't know who broke up with it but one
day they broke up
and five minutes later he was with
vanessa morgan and then they got married
and it's like oh damn like this is so
real
yeah so of course anytime we speak about
vanessa morgan i'm always interested
because the biermann connection is so
fascinating a reality star
and a tv star like it's just so rare you
know
yeah no it is quite rare that it's an
interesting little
young hollywood moment
triangle but it's not a triangle because
like no there was never seem to be any
beef but it's just an interesting
factoid you know
we do like to just remember where
everyone came from it's so important to
remember where you come from in order to
understand where you're going
1000 so another reason why i thought
this photo was so interesting and when
we posted it on our instagram people
were very quick to point out
um in the
instagram caption she pretty much only
uses i
as a pronoun not like we're so excited
we are keeping this private it's like
i'm so excited i feel like this is meant
to happen to me
it was just all very first person which
begs the question
are her and michael kopeck not together
anymore she still has their wedding
pictures and their wedding was kind of
recently so
she still has the wedding pictures up on
her instagram he is not tagged in them
but he deleted his instagram as far as i
know like a while ago okay
um and there's just like confusion
got it i i hear why that's weird you
know
typically people say we i mean maybe
there is something going on or maybe you
know he doesn't want to be
they don't want their relationship to be
out in the public anymore because
everybody has an opinion and that's
actually something that i can respect
i mean that's something we spoke about
on the patreon with olivia
yesterday because we were talking about
mary morris how like she's decided to no
longer share
pictures of her son on social media
because she got backlash literally for
the dumbest thing ever and she was like
just over and people were just so mean
and quick to judge like and olivia's
like honestly like i totally get that
and i respect that and olivia's probably
going to do the same
so um i totally respect people's
need for privacy and also maybe it's
like he doesn't want to be
he doesn't want to be on instagram he
doesn't want to be on social media she
like she says she thought about keeping
this private that's probably what they
maybe both wanted at first but now this
is like her journey and she's going to
share
just her piece of it she might not but
like he might not be down for that
she's just sharing her experience it's
very possible but i do think that is an
interesting factoid yeah that you
pointed out
also um i just want to update everyone
because kanye did visit the hospital
after his apology
um a source said that kanye has been
experiencing a lot of anxiety lately he
has been surrounded by a lot of people
and started to feel really overwhelmed
he decided to go to the hospital to get
checked out upon his arrival kanye
decided he'd rather be seen at home
he headed back to his home an ambulance
followed kanye was treated and his
doctor says his vitals are normal and
he's feeling much better oh good
okay update on that love to hear it um
we're going to jump into our tv recap
segment we are going to break down our
toast movie of the week which was black
panther and then into some of the stuff
we watched this weekend things we loved
and things we didn't love the kissing
booth too
and our tv recap segment is brought to
you by stamps.com as we slowly adjust to
a new normal we will still need to be
smart about how we do business
luckily there's stamps.com to make
things easier thousands of small
business owners have discovered
the benefits of stamps.com in recent
months they've been able to keep their
businesses running and avoid the crowds
at the post office
all from their own computers with
stamps.com you can print postage on
demand and avoid going to the post
office
and you'll save money with discounted
rates you can't even get at the post
office stamps.com also offers ups
services with discounts up to 62
and no residential surcharges stamps.com
brings all the mailing and shipping
services you need right to your computer
in the comfort of your own home or
office whether you're a small business
sending invoices an online seller
shipping out products or
just working from home and need to mail
stuff stamps.com can handle it all with
ease
simply use your computer to print
official u.s postage
24 7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
once your mail is ready you just leave
it for your mail carrier schedule a
pickup and
drop it off in the mailbox it's that
simple and like we said with stamps.com
you get great discounts too
five cents off every stamp and up to 62
percent off usps and ups shipping rates
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money
right now our listeners will get a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus
free postage and a digital scale without
any long-term commitment
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in
toast t-o-a-s-t again that's stamps.com
enter code
toast thank you stamps.com for
sponsoring today's episode
stamps.com let's do it black panther
what were your thoughts
okay so i love to just watch a movie
that is like has completely
just taken over the world like so
exciting to see like what all the hype
was about yeah
now i'm not so into like superhero
movies is what i've learned i haven't
seen that many
some most some like i'm the last one i
watched was like aquaman i wasn't like
crazy about it because like all of the
like fighting and the technology and
then you have to understand the
technology in order to understand how
they're going to be defeated
with the fighting like that's just not
really like my genre
but i thought so much about it was so
cool i thought the some of the casting
was so great
one of my favorite um things about it
was that
the villain claw you know who he is
right no
richard from 13 going on 30. oh
richard the boss the boss oh
jackie at first i was like who is this
guy he's so familiar he's so right there
and i couldn't put my finger on it and i
googled him and
once i saw his face outside of being a
superhero
it's richard i'm so glad he's still
working that brings me
so much joy he was a really good villain
and zach
always says like um a great like
superhero movie is only as good as the
villain
so i try and like watch everything
through that lens sometimes and i think
the fact that we had like two villains
yep was so great but i wasn't totally
like
against michael b jordan you know i
think i made some valid points i think
he did too and so i didn't like the way
that whole thing played out i feel like
it could have been solved in a kind of
better way
um as far as just like story lines go
you know you know i feel like they
couldn't decide whether they wanted
michael b jordan to be like all bad
because
while yes he was irrational with like
the burning of the black panther liquid
and he was like
he was the mad king like he was crazy he
literally said burn them all
yeah yeah he was really driven by this
concept that i kind of agreed with it's
like yes what's happening in wakanda is
amazing
but to not share the resources outside
of their own community with their black
community that is suffering in other
places
isn't that wrong yeah so i feel like
they stole his idea and then let him die
yeah so at first i was like well he kind
of has a good idea why do they have to
make him take it so far but i guess
that's like a commentary on just human
beings like nobody is
perfect even if you have the right idea
people get carried away with power
yeah you know but i didn't think that he
had to die
no i didn't think he was gonna die yeah
i didn't think he was gonna die and even
when he said like come on will
will will help you and he was like i
don't want to be in chains i thought
that um chadwick was going to be like
no i want you to you know be on my
council no they like let him die i
thought that was weird too like i
i wasn't fully satisfied with the ending
i thought chadwick boseman was
amazing like a really fabulous actor i
had one major problem with the movie and
it was sterling k
brown because to me like he is just so
cemented in my brain as like a suburban
dad
i don't know why like pro partially from
his character and this is us but just
like seeing him on red carpets he's like
kind of nerdy
and like i was just not buying that he
was like a traitorous villain
for one minute like i was not buying
anything he was selling me and i'm like
is that sterling came around
i just i wasn't buying it at all and it
was like
he was like acting and it was like
making me laugh like it just i wasn't
i wasn't into his casting at all
i i i hear that but i also think maybe
it was good because he was kind of like
undercover
in the us yes like you would never
suspect so you would yeah
so it didn't that didn't bother me
necessarily
but i hear what you're saying i thought
lupita nyong'o was fabulous
and it could have really dealt with like
more airtime for her love story because
the love story seemed kind of random
yeah and kind of rushed you know at the
end they like get back they get
back together i think they have been
together in the past because like of
everything that they had been through
but like it would have been nice to see
them like fall in love more along the
way yeah there were two things that i
thought the movie was really
important and i think why it resonated
with so many people the first is like
clearly the metaphor of like wakanda
being like everyone thinks they know
what wakanda is but like it's actually
like this flourishing community
i think is like a metaphor for you know
the black community it's like everyone
thinks that they know and everyone has
like kind of
judgments but it's like you really don't
know what the black community like it's
thriving you know
so i think it was like um i think i
think if i'm reading it correctly
it was like a metaphor and um
and been watched with me because ben's
not really into superhero movies like at
all
and ben was just like excited that i had
to watch one so he was watching with me
and he was really pointing out it's like
can you just believe like this movie was
made in 2019 it's like
why is there such a lack of diversity in
marvel which is like this
there's not five marvel movies there's
five marvel movies a year like it's not
that hard
so it was this kind of like cultural
reset and for that i think the movie is
spectacular yes
you know i agree with that and it
shouldn't have taken so long yeah and
there were like funny
bits throughout where it's like when she
says about this she's like what are
those and it's like oh it's it's still
it's like so culturally relevant even
though it's taking place in like a
you know far-off world well so that was
the other thing it's like as far as i
knew i thought it was about like a
made-up place
so then it's like the movie opens in
oakland california and i was so confused
like i thought this was like a fantasy
yeah and then they came into the real
world yeah whereas like sometimes it
takes
like a superhero movie like takes place
like in a different time or yeah future
yeah right right but then i guess like
ben made me watch batman and like it
takes place in new york and like
it's very like i just i get confused
between like superhero movies and then
like
cartoons you know or and like like
sci-fi
star wars totally totally oh it's hot in
here today
yeah but that's also like wonder woman
takes place during
world war ii so i never saw wonder woman
like i really don't like superhero
movies yeah but i actually i do like the
aspect where it's kind
it kind of is like historical fiction
they're re they're telling a story about
a certain
time in history and the outcome of these
superhero events
affects the right the course of history
again not my genre
but i totally um like i got the hype and
the music was so good
in um black panther that was like a
great element that really
elevated the movie so good two things
one um
the whole story line with the cia guy
who they brought and healed and then he
was like part of the crew i just like i
didn't understand
his purpose and it was never really made
clear whether or not he like ran back to
america and told them like because he
was like a foreign spy so it's like
did they tell the cia back at home like
all about the gadgets and gizmos aplenty
and the who's it and what's its galore
i don't think that he did because he
seemed maybe he even stayed like he was
like a true ally
yeah he was he really was maybe he was
there so that they could have
information about michael b jordan
but it just it was kind of strange and
then the second part was that
um the tribe what are they called jabari
i just i love them so much me too the
king was
everything of the sort the so hot
literally i loved them and it's like
at first i was like are these guys bad
or good because they wanted to overthrow
um chadwick boseman but when they lost
they didn't rebel like they just
they took it they took they took the
loss and then it was like they went back
and and needed the jabari's help and
they they really reminded me of the
dothraki and they like came in on
horseback with their like feather
yeah it actually did remind me of game
of thrones a little bit when
they're having that battle uh outside
the castle i guess yes
and they're all being circled in which
literally happened in the battle of the
bastards
and then the from the side
comes uh jabari jabari but also that's
literally what happened with the battle
of the bastards when from the side came
littlefinger's peeps yeah um it was
it was good you know i don't think it
was my favorite that we've watched yet
but i get it now yeah i get it and i'm
glad i saw it and it was really cool um
our next
film is if beale street could talk which
has come very highly recommended
was nominated and won a bunch of oscars
maybe last year of the year before that
um so yeah make sure to watch it and
we'll be recapping a week from today
can't wait i also really want to talk
about the kissing booth um and indian
matchmaking which are two things that i
watched this weekend
well i can't say watched for the kissing
booth because i barely made it through
45 minutes
you've been so hard on the kissing booth
like well you know what
you you're right you i haven't you
haven't because this is what happened
for people who are just tuning in
you know recently you loved kissing
booth one you loved it so much i watched
it so many times and i felt like it
transported me to like a time in my life
when like i was in high school and like
i just i thought it was the most amazing
one it was so well done obviously like
the
you know bella and edward style of real
life love between joey and jacob
really transports the movie makes it
extremely believable and it is really
well done in terms of how they portray
high school events and you
loved it you loved it so much i did and
it also like created an entirely new
genre on netflix
that then all these movies came to
follow like to all the boys before so
then what happened was you saw to all
the boys i loved before and you turned
on kissing because you want to know why
the kissing was
really had to walk so that to all the
boys could run
and when i went back and watched a
kissing booth after seeing to all the
boys i loved before i'm like this movie
is a piece of [ __ ] like it's
it's just it's cubic zirconium versus
diamonds like it's just
it's it's not even the same and so with
the sequel i feel like
it's so strange what's going on because
the sequel took
100 years to come out we got to all the
boys i loved before one
after the kissing booth and the to all
the boys sequel came out before the
kissing
sequel i don't know why it took so long
i had so many problems with the sequel
i mean what made the kissing booth great
was that like you knew that
jacob lordy and joey king were dating
and that like it was so cute that they
met on set
and now we know not only are they not
dating he's dating zendaya and they
do not get along like joey and jacob
yeah it is so palpable in the movie
jackie
jacob lordy feels like he just would be
anywhere else besides this movie set
like he's just dying to go back to
euphoria it's just
there's this palpable weirdness joey
king is wearing a wig the whole time
and it's just very ill-fitting and i'm
i just was so disinterested it just the
magic was
so lost yeah that's really rough i feel
like even when they were
dating post kissing booth one i wasn't
feeling the need for a kissing booth too
because
all that's left to do is to break up
this couple because he goes to college
right
and now that the magic is lost like i
understand they're gonna make a lot of
money from the movie and
something did good so let's keep doing
it again until we beat it into the
ground
there's a third one already filmed but
like the what we had the magic of
kissing with one was so special like
sometimes you just have to leave it at
that because it can't be recreated
especially because
these two broke up no sometimes you
gotta leave well enough alone
i totally agree and i haven't even
watched kissing booth too yet and i
don't know if i will because i have
like so much on my list right now it's
just i keep saying i really i mean i
didn't even finish it but
to me there were just so many things
that made no [ __ ] sense like elle's
like she was always gonna go to uc
berkeley and then she's like going to
apply to some boston schools
so she could be near noah and i don't
know what ended up happening but she's
like applying to harvard it's like
you can't just apply to harvard because
you decided to it's like she was
applying to boston college um
bu and it's like you don't apply to bu
and harvard they were talking about
harvard like it was community college
like
like anyone could just applying it and
it was bothering me so much
that's so funny and then there's this
girl at college that like joey king is
obviously jealous of because she's like
so beautiful and worldly and she like
walks into the restaurant and is
speaking french
and joey just feels like a true high
schooler in front of this girl who's
been hanging out with jacob mallory and
her his new friends
and literally in no world is this a
college student she's 100 years old like
no she's like
25 but like she's just the least college
college student
ever got it wow you know what i'm just
thinking about now like
there i just saw that the next one's
going to come out in 2021 and like i'm
assuming l will be in college but like
college is so different right now like
we
the students didn't really have a spring
semester fall is pretty much going to be
virtual
yeah i wonder if like i mean probably
kissing booth won't do it
a virtual college session but yeah some
of these shows are going to have to like
incorporate
what the quarantine into if it's a show
about you know a crime not
like i'm watching billions right now and
what's crazy is it must have been filmed
in
january or february because um in the
last episode that they put out
wags mentions coronavirus oh so
now it's like obviously current virus
would affect bobby axelrod's entire
business like
is is bobby axelrod and quarantine is
the next season just bobby axelrod
inquiring
right i mean we know for sure hardware
enthusiasm is going to be acknowledging
the pandemic
this has now gone on far too long for
for any show to really just skip over it
because like what were their characters
doing and but
the thing is i don't want to watch about
people in quarantine i know especially
once we're out of here
it's depressing but like this
you know that is the situation so it's
just interesting
um the other thing i watch how will the
corner pirates affect yellowstone
the dutton ranch who knows who knows
um me and ben fell in love with indian
matchmaking on netflix
this weekend um i just heard good things
about it like i
some people had like negative things to
say about it in terms of like its
cultural
meaning but to be honest i absolutely
loved it and i
loved learning about indian culture
especially as it pertains to marriage
because so much of it reminded me of
jewish culture it's just like every mom
nagging their sound like when you're
getting married when they're getting
married it's literally all they talk
about
um and i mean i just i loved it first of
all it was so interesting because when
you think of a ranged marriage you think
of kind of like a traditional
version of it which i don't think has
existed for a while where it's like
forced by the parents
no she's really i don't even i don't
even think they should be using the word
arranged marriage because she's a
matchmaker through and through she's
like a virtual dating app like
she finds you matches she sends you the
bio data which is like
name picture age job fun facts about you
you get choices
of course and you go on a date if you
don't like them you you say bye like
it's really not an arranged marriage but
they talk about
two types of marriages in india even
though the matchmaker is very prominent
in india but she comes to the states for
american indians she said there's two
types of marriages there's an arranged
marriage and a love marriage and a love
marriage is like you just meet someone
but then it implies that the arranged
marriage like doesn't have love which it
really
does because it's not an arranged
marriage it's a setup i understand
honestly from what i understand some
arrange marriages or set up marriages
are the most successful well so they
started every episode with an arranged
marriage
um couple who are have been married for
40 50 60 years
it was so funny they're like so
hilarious and so cute
and just and of course there are bad
marriages whether you get married
via arranged marriage or love love
marriage and i don't know i just think
that like
the show aimed to deal
with it doesn't feel right to call it a
love marriage because it you're
there i feel like the word needs to be
like a felon like a
marriage where you fell right so like i
just feel like the show was meant to
deconstruct some of the things you might
think about like modern
arranged marriages in india and i feel
like it did a good job of that
and i mean some of the characters that
were on the show were just true
characters aparna
the whoa like she was bothering me so
much she was from but whatever i don't
want to get into it because like
towards the end like the show really did
lose me they just like kept changing
they're like three singles here three
singles there
and if you spoiler alert none of the
couples are together now
like not a single one um so at the end
it started to feel like a waste of time
but yeah
in the beginning at least one to route
four to rally that's like any show
love is blind even the bachelor like
without those successful couples in the
past
this show it has it doesn't have lag to
stand so like it ended kind of weirdly
but like the first six out of eight
episodes i was living for it and the
best part of the whole show was this
matchmaker she's like very
world-renowned like her she flies all
around the world meets with clients
is in airports if she sees an indian
person she's like hi i'm sema blah blah
and she walks into someone's house and
she comes to the house she meets the
family it's really
indian marriages are not between really
a man and a woman it's between two
families
so it's like when they meet for the
first time the families come and then
they go out on a date by themselves but
so she walks into the house
and she's like hi i'm sima from mumbai
she literally everywhere she goes hi i'm
sima from mumbai sema
she always says she's from mumbai and is
so funny i'm like if she keeps saying
is that her last name or she keeps
saying sima from mumbai she just says hi
i'm sema from mumbai
she herself was an absolute legend like
just giving some of these singles like
the cold hard truth like you gotta
get get it together you gotta stop being
so negative like some of these people
like had
you know walls within themselves that
she had to break down
um but again like what you learned about
indian culture was so fascinating like
literally if you make a match she would
take their pictures to a face reader
and he would be able to tell within
minutes if they're a match he's like
he showed a picture of aparna and he was
like this girl's very stubborn
yeah she is like he could just really
know so much about that look for
i don't know he didn't say he didn't
reveal the message but it was just crazy
like the different methods and then they
they really believe in astrology so they
give the charts of two people that are
really getting along
and show it to like a world famous
astrologer and it's like what does it
mean
and there was a couple you know vyasar
who was starting to get along with this
girl and they did not match like at all
and he was right because literally like
they were facetime dating for two weeks
and they couldn't stop fighting like
there really is so much to it and they
believe so firmly in these things and it
was really cool like
i really enjoyed it it sounds really
good
it was i'm gonna add it to my list
because you
making it sound really good and then you
just learned so much about the region
like there was a nadia who was like
everyone's favorite she was just like
this sweet sweet sweet girl who just
like
couldn't find the right guy
and she was guyanese and i
honestly had never i didn't know what
that meant and it's like this
region in southeast asia i think where a
lot of indians
were transported or something so it's
like a lot of people in the indian
community don't consider her to be
indian because she's guyanese
got it and then simon told me what
happened ended up finding her
a guyanese guy in new york it was just
it was beautiful it was and of course
none of the couples ended up together
but
not even those two no and she didn't
even like the guyanese guy didn't work
out she ended up with this
cutie from chicago shaker his name was
and
they like went off into the sunset and
you just assumed that they were together
forever
and um they're not damn
it it's hard to watch now knowing that
it doesn't work out
but it was just there were funny moments
it was just really really good
okay wow great wreck thank you yeah
anything else you watch this weekend
well just yellowstone which a lot of
people have been suggesting it is on
peacock originally on paramount network
and it's like kevin costner
and um other people who
so many actors who look like other
actors like the sun casey to me looks
like a mixture of garrett hedlund
and um tim riggins oh santa
and avery from nashville no it's really
good it starts off really slow and it's
really kind of brutal and intense and at
first i was like this is
not suitable for campers um but i think
it tells like a real story of what goes
on in
in montana um and because there's so
much
like forestry and animals out there and
and
livestock and it's really really
interesting i think the show is really
well done
it's so beautiful it's the farm chairman
like it's the farm chairman life
you've been dreaming of some tv shows
like impact your mental health in the
sense
where i am when i watch vanderpump rules
like i always want to go out and get
drunk with my friends and i feel like if
i watch montana like i would just want
to retire on a farm
yeah well like that's always what i want
for myself if i watch yellowstone not if
i watch montana sorry
it's always what i want so it's just
like in like reaffirms that
in me so hopefully i can find like a
yellowstone
raw scenic ride on peloton too oh yeah
but i think that you should watch it
okay because right now i'm in the middle
of season two
i'm not sure if there's a season three i
hope that there is because it's one of
those shows where it's like it's not
like everything's popping off left and
right but like when you're in it it
transports you're in a whole new world
kind of like the crown it's exactly like
the crown it's like not everything's
moving if you if you don't understand
what someone said in one line like you
don't need to rewind
yeah but overall you're just in another
place
fabulous yeah um also over the weekend
shay coulee was announced
the drag queen all-stars winner um of
course this was the least shocking news
i've heard all day the season was
literally made so that she could get
justice because she deserved to win on
her season
and that's that on that i said it from
day one she's toasty as hell and we st
in this house we [ __ ] stand shake
outlay and i'm just look at me do i look
surprised
no because i'm not you don't i'm not
surprised
because i'm not no you don't like it
actually i look a little surprised right
now my eyebrows are kind of high but i
was just it was her time you know
like the san francisco 49ers oh speaking
of eyebrows um watching say yes to the
dress made me feel
so good about my decision to get botox
and to continue to get botox
because the the frown line like was
crazy and it's like i'm so much younger
there
and my my forehead's all over the place
and it wasn't even like i wasn't even on
the show but you could see my frown line
you were on the show yeah but like not
even um
anything else it got really hot in here
and i'm ready to go we've talked about
so much i think i really think this is
an episode where we've talked about the
most we've ever talked about because
every story had like a sub story we
talked about like a million different
shows
so i believe that is all she wrote her
hand must be hurting
i mean my thighs are chafing so her hand
must be hurting okay
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast millennium morning
show we post videos on our youtube
channel monday through friday and we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i heart
radio cast box
all the places wherever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning to leave a
five-star review about a beautiful
stunning and smart we are we love you
guys very much and we will see you
tomorrow
[Music]
goodbye
you